[Music]
wow
hey there i'm lord garrett and welcome
to an action-packed new rt essentials
today we are celebrating the bravest in
the biz the ones keeping it real when
the stakes are high these are the actors
who aren't afraid to lay down their
lives on the line for the sake of
entertainment challenging those pesky
naysayers who sit there saying there's
no way they actually pulled up
the majority of movie stars aren't like
jackie chan and tom cruise who could
each have the entire episode dedicated
to all the dangerous stunts they've
performed but that wouldn't leave time
to celebrate the other notable actors
who have done the same
don't worry chan and cruz are still on
this list
obviously
without further ado i present to you the
most dangerous stunts by real actors
this means no doubles no cgi face
replacements or deep bass the actor you
see performing the stunt is really the
actor
hanging from the side of a plane tom
cruise mission impossible rogue nation
benji open that door right now yeah i'm
trying
and flying in first is none other than
tom cruise who hangs from the side of a
plane in mission impossible rogue nation
in this fifth mi installation written
and directed by christopher macquarie
agent ethan hunt gathers his horses to
fight against a new network of highly
skilled operatives known as the
syndicate the syndicate is dedicated to
establishing a new world order by
escalating a series of terrorist attacks
and hunt's mission to prevent these
attacks might be his most impossible yet
but stopping the syndicate doesn't seem
as impossible as dangling from an airbus
a400m at 5 000 feet in the air while
sporting a business suit to tackle this
speech cruiser's stunt coordinator wade
eastwood drew up plans that would ensure
the megastar faced as little danger as
possible these plans included a safety
harness and a special rig inside the
plane's door that would pull crews into
the aircraft in case of an emergency
additionally safety goggles were off
limits but with winds of up to 185 miles
per hour any sort of debris could be
extremely dangerous so kruger was fitted
with special contact lenses to help
deflect particles but couldn't really
protect him from what eastwood saw as
the biggest threat
birds
see it is a legitimate fear for some yes
there were no safety measures that could
stop a bird strike so risk was minimized
by putting a spotter in the cockpit
makes you wonder what would happen if
birds realised how powerful they were
and teamed up against us
the other door right yes the other door
okay yes yes sorry sorry i bought my
back
luckily the birds were no match for
crews and after eight takes both the
actor and director were satisfied enough
to move on all macquarie had to do in
post was edit out the wires and
additional cameras that were strapped to
the plane did i mention cruz was the one
pushing to have this stunt in the film
and that it's the opening sequence
where do you go from there buddy
hanging onto the hood of a car zoe bell
grind house presents death proof
check it out
hanging on the hood of a car is the most
gripping stunt in tarantino's grind
house presents death proof pun intended
kiwi zoe bell is a real-life stunt woman
who plays herself and while shooting a
film in lebanon tennessee her and her
two friends test drive a 1970 dodge
challenger the same type of car used in
the 1971 classic vanishing point belle
insists on playing a game called ship's
mast where she rides on the hood of a
challenger at high speeds holding onto
belts that are fastened to the car's
body her friends abernathy and kim are
hesitant but belle won't be deterred and
as the car is whipping down the winding
roads of lebanon she climbs out of the
passenger side window and hangs from the
car's hood shouting with excitement the
fun quickly turns to terror as their
stalker stuntman mike played by kurt
russell catches up with belle and her
friends and tries to use his dodge
charger to run their challenger off the
road smashing into it repeatedly
oh
tarantino had been so impressed with
belle after she worked as uma thurman
stunt double and kill bill that he
decided to cast her in the leading role
in death proof belle insisted on pulling
off this dangerous stunt without a
double even though tarantino was
hesitant at first now that belle was a
main character and all it didn't take
much convincing though and the two
pulled one off as the best car chases in
decades bell admitted in an interview
that there was no double no cgi and that
it's all practical and you're seeing
that the person crying is the same one
who's falling off the car and that's a
perfect example of the reason people
have such a visceral response to that
sequence
mall pole slide jackie chan police story
jackie chan wrote directed starred and
performed his own stunts in the 1985
action comedy police story it's the tale
of detective kakui who must protect a
female witness from the hong kong drug
lord she once worked for kakui helps
arrest the drug lord but is then forced
to clear his name after being accused of
murder the film is loaded with
large-scale action sequences like a car
chase through a shanty town and a scene
where chan dangles from a seating
double-decker bus but the most notable
stunt and arguably one of the greatest
stunts in action cinema history is the
mall pole slide performed by chan
towards the end of the film chan's
character is chasing and fighting
criminals in a shopping mall which
culminates in him having to jump from a
high level onto a metal pole and slide
down several stories look i know it
doesn't sound as crazy as hanging from a
plane or from the hood of a challenger
but this stunt almost cost chan his life
just the jump from the railing to the
pole was dangerous enough if chan failed
to properly grab the pole he risked a
long fall to the ground below and there
was no wire or safety net involved
additionally the pole itself was
surrounded by decorative lights that
chan was meant to break while sliding
down
chan was concerned that he could get
shocked by the bursting electrical
lights but he was assured that they'd be
switched off if anything went wrong
despite precautions an error with the
lighting caused the pole to be heated to
a high temperature
chan managed to latch onto the burning
hot pole and slide down to safety
without loosening his grip but he
suffered second-degree burns on his
hands still this didn't stop him from
running off to shoot scenes from the
film heart of dragon in the same day
what a legend
jumping onto a moving bus keanu reeves
speed
i gotta get on that bus you gotta get
him
yeah yeah you get on the bus
drive straight
stay in this lane
are you in short
yeah what
keanu reeves is not only known for
having a career that has spanned decades
but also for being one of the nicest
guys alive
and as one of the leading action heroes
of our time hey that is a pretty damn
impressive list long before neo and john
wick reeves played jack an lapd officer
in the 1994 thriller speed
jack is tasked with preventing a
terrorist from blowing up a bus filled
with civilians if the bus falls below 50
miles per hour the bomb detonates and
it's game over which is precisely why
reeves had to perform the jumping onto a
moving bus stunt well he didn't have to
they could have opted to use a double
but reeves insisted he pulled this one
off himself in fact director jean de
bonte originally forbade reeves from
attempting this stunt i guess he didn't
want his lead actor hopping from a
speeding jaguar convertible onto a bus
while weaving through traffic who knows
why
drive straight
despite the director's wishes reeves
secretly practiced jumping from a moving
car onto a bus and when it came time to
shoot begged to bond to let him try to
stunt himself the director reluctantly
agreed and the stunt that you see in the
film is actually reeves this leads me to
a very important question how exactly
does one practice jumping from a moving
car onto a bus fighting outside a
helicopter jason statham crank
you ever heard the expression choose
your battles i just don't think jason
stacem has otherwise he probably
wouldn't have chosen to perform the
fighting outside a helicopter stunt in
the movie crank where he plays hitman
chev chelios chev wakes up to a phone
call informing him that he's been
poisoned and only has an hour to live
unless he keeps adrenaline coursing
through his body while he searches for
an antidote by the end of the film cheb
finds himself fist fighting a bad guy
while dangling from a helicopter that
hovers 3000 feet above downtown la
statham chose to perform the majority of
the stanson prank including this one
where there was only one slim safety
wire to keep him from falling to his
death interestingly johnny knoxville was
originally considered for the lead role
which makes me think that writer
director duo mark neville dean and brian
taylor knew they'd be putting their
actors through the ringer taylor stated
that any actor who did crank was going
to be as crazy as him and neville dean
are and statham proved to be just the
right amount of crazy
[Music]
during the sequence the stuntman on set
repeatedly asked statham if he was sure
he wanted to do this and production
stressed that they absolutely didn't
want him doing this and that if he did
it was of his own volition probably for
insurance reasons when asked if he had
to train for this stunt statham simply
replied how do you train for hanging out
of helicopter just go and do it maybe
you should have contacted reeves to see
you get a secret helicopter hanging
practice space you know next to his bus
jumping one unlike those actors i did
not land that joke
jumping on to moving trucks angelina
jolie salt
wow
not that you needed another reason to
love angelina jolie but did you know the
iconic actress performs 99 of her own
stunts like the one where she jumps onto
moving trucks in the 2010 action
thriller salt jolie plays evelyn salt a
cia officer who gets accused of being a
russian spy and must evade capture by
going on the run and becoming a fugitive
all while trying to prove her innocence
yes that is also the theme of some of
the bourne movies
salt finds herself cornered by agents on
an overpass and must choose to either
succumb to the arrest or jump into the
oncoming traffic below getting some
serious harrison ford in the fugitive
vibes and much like ford and the
fugitive jolly jumps to evade her
captors only it's actually jolie
performing this daring stunt leaping off
the bridge and landing on top of a
speeding container truck
no i didn't do anything
according to producer lorenzo de
bonaventura jolie was prepared and ready
to do any stunt and they had her jumping
out of helicopters shooting jumping off
all sorts of things and infiltrating
places that are impossible to infiltrate
stunt coordinator simon crane confirmed
that jolie did in fact pull off this
epic jump on her own and added that they
rehearsed everything with doubles but
angelina was really game
director philip noyce was horrified by
her eagerness to endanger herself but
hey if jolly wants to leap off a bridge
she's gonna leap off a bridge
this scene was shot component by
component as opposed to one long
sequence jolie would jump off the bridge
noyce would then cut then they'd shoot
the next component jolie flying through
the air they'd cut then set up for the
next shot where jolly jumps onto another
moving vehicle this technique helped to
minimize safety risks but still fly
would not have done it hold on how much
were they paying her
slingshot porta potty stevo jackass
three
you ready
the stars of jackass have always
performed their own stunts often
suffering serious injuries in the
process for anyone who might be
unfamiliar with the television show
turned film series it's basically a
group of friends who constantly prank
each other and seem to have an
incredible high tolerance for pain the
danger that you're witnessing is real no
double no special effects and film after
film the stumps get more ridiculous like
the slingshot port-a-potty scene in
jackass 3 also known as the pooh
cocktail supreme
[Music]
this time it's jackass legend stevo in
the hot seat and by the hot seat i mean
strapped to the used porta potty toilet
ah this stunt was based on what was
known as the pooh cocktail originally
performed by johnny knoxville in the
very first episode of jackass part of
the premise of jackass 3 was to revisit
older stunts but revamp them with higher
stakes and shock value so instead of
having the person in the porta potty be
flipped upside down by a garbage truck
like in the original stunt they decided
to use bungee cords to launch the porta
potty high into the air
showering stevo in dog
feces supreme
oh yeah
[Music]
originally stevo had suggested having
the porta potty bungee down off a bridge
but director jeff tremaine had the
brilliant idea of launching it up into
the air instead using industrial cranes
despite all the dangerous often painful
stunts stevo has pulled off over the
years he was particularly terrified
during this one in an interview he
admitted that he has an irrational fear
of roller coasters and bungee jumping
even though he felt safe being in a five
point harness for this stunt it's one of
the most viscerally unappealing and
disgusting stunts or moments ever
captured on film but hey
that's jackass
running from the boulder harrison ford
raiders of the lost ark
next up is the iconic running from the
boulder stunt in raiders of the lost ark
harrison ford plays dr indiana jones a
renowned archaeologist who is hired by
the us government to find the ark of the
covenant which is believed to still hold
the ten commandments indiana and his
ex-lover marion must stop the nazis from
finding the ark first and in doing so
escape various close calls like a giant
boulder that comes very close to
flattening indiana like a pancake though
i'm sure the average person is familiar
with this sequence it's been parodied
countless times in popular culture just
don't think most people realize just how
dangerous this stunt was for ford
director steven spielberg later admitted
that he was an idiot for letting ford
perform this stunt his words not ours
but due to the nature of the scene ford
had to run directly towards the camera
as the giant rock followed after him
using a double would have made this shot
incredibly difficult they would have had
to have held their head down to hide the
fact that they aren't forward also keep
in mind that this was 1981 so no cgi or
fancy technology to rely on though the
boulder wasn't an actual boulder
obviously it was still 12 feet tall and
weighed 300 pounds it could have easily
done bodily harm to ford had he tripped
or just simply not outrun it he would
have died by the boulder or
embarrassment it took ten nail-biting
takes for spielberg to be satisfied
which meant ten close calls for ford
house
king steamboat bill jr
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
roger ebert once wrote of buster
keaton's extraordinary period from 1920
to 1929 in which he worked without
interruption and became one of the
greatest actor directors in the history
of the movies orson welles even called
keaton a supreme artist and one of the
most beautiful people who was ever
photographed yes keaton was an
extraordinary talent with a career that
lasted well into the 60s but he also
didn't make it past the shooting of the
silent film steamboat bill jr in 1928
and we can blame that on the house full
stunt in which a 4 000 pound front side
of a house falls forward and narrowly
misses keaton thanks to a perfectly
placed attic window
in the film a tornado wreaks havoc on a
small town and keaton's character
william canfield jr is caught in the
middle of it he gets tossed around by
the harsh winds but manages to stand and
catch his balance just before the heavy
house collapses around him keaton
remains standing avoiding certain injury
and possible death by only a few inches
it goes without saying but there were no
special effects back then no cgi
heck there weren't even sounds on film
yet keaton had to stand on a very
precise mark in order for this stunt to
work no room for error according to
hollywood legend keaton's shoes were
nailed down on his mark so he wouldn't
be tempted to move
keaton later recalled that crew members
were praying during this scene and the
cameraman had to look away as the shot
rolled
this stunt has been imitated countless
times since the release of steamboat
bill jr hopefully in a somewhat safer
manner
dangling from and piloting a helicopter
tom cruise mission impossible fall out
last but not least we circle back to tom
cruise this time he's dangling from and
piloting a helicopter in mission
impossible fallout the sixth installment
in the series cruz returns is ethan hunt
who joins forces with a cia assassin
named august walker or if you're
american argus walker to prevent an epic
disaster involving plutonium like every
mi movie the stakes get higher the
action gets more intense and cruz pulls
off some death-defying stunt that leaves
audiences stunned for this one it's as
if cruz saw statham and crank and
thought to himself hey
i can do that i'll even one-up him by
also flying the helicopter myself and
that's exactly what he did for the first
part of this sequence cruz hangs from
the landing skids of a helicopter as it
tows a cargo load below 1200 feet up in
the air at one point he slips and falls
roughly 40 feet landing hard on the
cargo load as it dangles though crews
had safety harnesses on the fall was
real and wanted the landing to be hard
so it looked authentic ugh i flinched
when i saw it
during one take crews missed the cargo
load and cast members panicked thinking
that he'd fallen to his death in an
interview rebecca ferguson expressed
that she heard herself scream and
actually thought he fell
she added that there was an audible gas
from the crowd that's just the half of
it cruz then flew the helicopter through
the mountains at low altitude for a
chase scene one that required him
getting dangerously close to another
helicopter
the crew developed special camera rigs
that face the inside of the helicopter
ensuring viewers that it was really
crews and crews alone piloting the actor
spent three months at a helicopter
school in texas in order to gain these
skills needed to pull off this stunt
which included a corkscrew nose dive one
of the most dangerous maneuvers a pilot
could attempt and there you have it our
picks for the most dangerous stunts by
real actors as always we couldn't
include every death defying feat that
fits the bill but there are plenty more
episodes of rt essentials coming your
way so i'm sure we'll get there
eventually thanks for tuning in i'm maud
garrett or as americans say mod garrett
yeah the real one no stump doubles here
[Music]
[Music]
you